first for lunch i'm using bacon
deliciously seductive in asani and great
for adding flavor and texture to thrifty
dishes because
a little goes a long long way my
favorite bacon
is traditional cured italian pancetta
rich and strong in flavor
it brings extra depth to salads stews
and soups
but a great cheap alternative is streaky
bacon
and it's what i'll be using for my
thrifty lunch
smoky bacon onions potatoes sweet corn
it's amazing how
cheap the ingredients are that go into
this
get your bacon and just cut into nice
chunks
i want these nice bite-sized pieces
smoky
chunky and just absolutely delicious
it's almost like an american corn
chowder
potatoes give it starch thickness sweet
corn gives it that glossy delicious
flavor
a couple of baileys they're always
hanging around if they're not in your
cupboard they're on someone's drive
so ask to borrow them they are so
powerful and it goes brilliantly well
with the onions and the bacon
bay leaves in a couple of potatoes
it's incredible how far you can stretch
something out
especially when you bulk it with
potatoes slice them
and dice them nice and chunky soups are
a fantastic way to use up leftover veg
or meat that might otherwise go to waste
and if you make it in bulk
freeze it in individual portions and
save on lunches throughout the week
so you can see already how hearty and
robust the soup is it's a
delicious combination onions bacon
potatoes and now some fresh leaks
open up the leak into four give that
a nice wash licks often have soil left
in their tops
so it's important to clean them
thoroughly start sweating that down
we haven't even got a corn in there yet
and already it's looking and smelling
incredible
add salt but remember you've got bacon
in there which is salty so
proceed with caution really important to
sweat those potatoes off
i love getting that flavor from the
smoky bacon
in with the potatoes now once the leek
is sweated off
creamed corn a popular side dish in the
states
creamed corn is made from fresh frozen
or even tinned corn
cooked with onion butter and cream and
can be bought ready made
that starts to give the foundation the
soup
half the creamed corn add the sweet corn
then your stock don't flood the soup
just bring the stock to underneath the
ingredients you can always add
very difficult to take away homemade
chicken stock is so cheap to make
just boil up your roast chicken bones
with a few fresh veg and freeze in
batches for when you need it
lighten the load with a touch of milk
that gives a really nice
bright color now bring that up to the
ball
turn it down and let it simmer for 12 to
15 minutes
as it cooks slowly the starch thickens
the soup
the bacon renders and that leek onion
starts to puree and the corn just shines
okay next we're going to make the
american cheese biscuits in the uk
they're known as scones but in america
they're called biscuits
[Music]
[Applause]
first put plain flour into a sieve add
baking powder
and sift both into a bowl next add some
salt
pepper and grated mature cheddar cheese
mix the dry ingredients then make it
well in the center
pour in double cream and gently combine
with a wooden spoon
turn your dough out onto a floured
surface and knead for a few seconds only
if you overwork it your cheese biscuits
won't rise
roll out your dough to about two
centimetres thick and cut into four
centimeter round biscuits
[Applause]
place well apart on a lined baking sheet
and leave to rest on the tray
for about 10 minutes then brush the top
of each biscuit
with melted butter and bake for about 30
minutes
at 160 degrees c in a preheated oven
when your cheese biscuits are well risen
and a beautiful golden brown
remove deliciously moorish served hot
or cold time to dole out my thrifty
lunch
i always like to leave a soup to stand
or rest
it looks richer it gets rid of all the
stock
i like to have two thirds ingredient one
third of the stock so it looks like a
nice
delicious chunky soup
into the bowl
[Music]
beautiful tin sweet corn a leek potato
and some streaky bacon but it doesn't
look like it's just coming out of a
stalker but
that is proper hearty food
[Music]
served with my american style cheese
biscuits this thrifty lunch may have
been made on a shoestring but without an
ounce of compromise on freshness and
flavor
[Music]
the secret of a great hash brown are the
potatoes
i prefer using really nice waxy potatoes
they cook better but more importantly
hold themselves together
we're not gonna slice the onion all the
potatoes but we're actually going to
grate them
the potatoes get really nice and crispy
i mean seriously crispy
now the onion
that way you get that nice balance of
the onion flavor running through
every little shard of potato
[Music]
season with salt pepper olive oil and km
give that a really good mix through
and then squeeze all that water out
and look at all that juice we squeeze
out there really important
the more liquid you remove the crispier
your hash browns will be
nice large pan put that on once the pan
is hot
pour in a good glug of olive oil
[Music]
that sound confirms how important it is
to have your pan
nice and hot so seals
the grated potato onion together so take
the spoon
and just pat it down what we're trying
to do now is get it really nice and
compact
go around the outside of the pan with
little flecks of butter
you just slip them down the back gently
and that gets the onions caramelised
here's a great tip for turning your hash
browns over
quick and easy take a plate
place it on top and just
flip it over and then slide it back in
very quickly you see the color
we've got on there now got that nice
crispy texture of the potato
i'm going to use the hash brown as a bed
for my baked eggs
crack in your eggs nice and gently just
a little sprinkling
of the cayenne to make the eggs a little
bit spicy
then into a preheated oven for six to
eight minutes
meanwhile onto my bacon and i'm giving
it a classic american twist
now one thing i could never get my head
around when i first started eating lots
of american breakfast was the
sweetness from the bacon i've grown up
to love that combination of smoky sweet
flavors
and it's so easy pan on and simply heat
olive oil
brown sugar salt and pepper and butter
bacon in and as it cooks it becomes
irresistibly caramelized and golden
brown
toaster gas and my glazed bacon
absolutely ready beautiful now my hash
browns and baked eggs are ready
at that beautiful just
put your spatula underneath there onto
your plate
and that bacon sets beauty on top of the
baked eggs and that hash brown
underneath and
you can see why the best breakfasts in
the world
are always in america
this is an all-american superhero offer
breakfast
eggs bait in hash browns with glazed
bacon
[Music]